hi I'm Phil thanks so much for joining
us today for the first stadia connect
this series gives you a look at stadia
news events new titles bonus features
and more we'll be posting these stadia
connect videos from time to time to
bring you the latest from Google
straight to all of you the players we've
got a bunch of exciting news to share
with you today so let's get started
three months ago we gave you a first
look at stadia a new generation game
platform powered by the best of Google
today we're gonna tell you about the
first wave of games available at launch
will share pricing details including an
exclusive launch offer and you'll learn
how to become one of the first stadia
players stadia has been years in the
making across different Google teams
googles mission has always been to make
information more accessible for everyone
with stadia our goal is to make gaming
more accessible for everyone too we
design stadia to bring together game
players and game watchers from around
the world into one global community of
gamers and stadia makes it easy to play
your favorite games on any screen in
your life at launch later this year
you'll be able to play stadia games on
your TV desktop laptop tablet and on
pixel smartphones starting with pixel
three as well as the brand new pixel 3a
that we announced last month
wherever you are stadia lets you play
the latest games no downloads no patches
no installs just grab your controller
and you're in this level of access and
availability represents a huge shift in
the gaming world instead of a console or
a PC you're using Google's data center
as the platform we handled the intense
gameplay processing and graphics so
there's no console required to play your
favorite games
that's what stadia is all about the
games today we're unveiling the very
first wave of games coming to the
platform
launch we're working with hundreds of
leading publishers and developers around
the world to deliver their biggest and
best titles to stadia we've lined up an
incredible selection of games spanning
nearly every genre including fighting
sport it's role-playing games
first-person action and racing titles
and we're just getting started this
worldwide exclusive unveil comes
straight from our friends at Larian
studios
[Music]
[Music]
so Lehren is a company where we try to
give everybody a lot of freedom because
we want them to come with our IDs thanks
man
forget it my name is Sam dinky I am the
founder and director of Lions to do so
learn series was founded in 97 and Ghent
and Belgium
I've seen the entire evolution of the
games industry we keep on driving the
state-of-the-art forward so fast you
don't have that in music you don't have
it in movies but the video games you
have it in stadia is like the next leap
I mean it is quite revolutionary large
studios was founded to be able to create
big epic RPGs in which the world reacts
to what you're doing in which you could
play together with your friends when we
release divinity origins in one
I tried approaching Wizards of the coast
trying to tell them that we should be
the ones making Baldur's Gate 3 they
didn't necessarily believe me back then
but then we started making divinity
original sin 2 and then at some point I
just reached out to me and I said well
you're the guy that wanted to make
Baldur's Gate 3 do you still want to
make Baldur's Gate 3 say yeah of course
I still want to make Baldur's Gate three
and that got the conversation rolling
and before he knew it we were
constructing story it was awesome I was
a geek dream come true
also gate 3 is the biggest game that
we've ever done we had to triple the
size from Studio to be able to do it
production values are very very very
high but the game deserves it
I mean it's people have been waiting on
it for a very long time so it deserves
to be top notch and every single aspect
and it's shaping up to be a beautiful
game but the coolest thing about it all
is that by bringing it to stadia pretty
much everybody is gonna be able to play
it at the highest quality settings
because stadia is democratic in that
sense if you want it doesn't
differentiate between what platform
you're playing at home because
everything is server based we can't wait
for you to play Baldur's Gate 3 on
stadia and whether you're playing an RPG
like Baldur's Gate 3 or any of the other
titles and genres we'll share today we
know that players demand the most
responsive experiences from their games
and we have architected stadia to give
you the fastest possible response
between what your fingers are doing
what your eyes are seeing so what does
that mean for the internet connection
you're on right now let's quickly dig
into the numbers our highest quality
gaming experience is remarkable with 4k
HDR video at 60 frames per second and
5.1 surround sound we're able to deliver
this experience to users with a
connection speed of around 35 megabits
per second and with Google handling the
processing load you can enjoy smooth
gameplay even if you don't have that
kind of connection so let's say you have
a connection speed of just 10 megabits
of a second you can still get at least
720p video at 60 frames per second with
stereo sound we're really proud of the
experience were able to deliver and it's
all thanks to more than 20 years of work
at Google building and optimizing our
networks and data centers to support
services with billions of users like
YouTube Gmail Android Google Play Maps
and of course Google search the latency
and speed demands of online gaming
aren't far off from the demands we've
been meeting for years we handle the
backend so you can play the games you
want when you want on whatever screen
you prefer back in October of 2018 we
put this idea to the test with projects
stream we invited users to stream
Assassin's Creed Odyssey at up to 1080p
and 60 frames per second it was a
phenomenal gaming experience on a wide
range of pcs and laptops that were
simply running a Chrome browser with
project stream we demonstrated that we
can transmit the live instance from the
data center to your screen faster than
your eye is transmitting those images to
your brain that's critical for fast
paced games on stadia like Mortal Kombat
it's truly a new paradigm for gaming and
since we announced stadia a few months
ago we've gotten a lot of interest about
this new way to play in our
conversations and meetups with game
developers they're excited about the
possibilities of an ever-evolving play
experience and we can't wait to get
stadia in the hands of gamers later this
year so let's share some more details
about the platform and what you'll need
to get started at law
you'll get the best experience playing
with our new stadium troller it's
designed specifically for streaming
games and it includes a capture button
for your game footage and a button to
access the Google assistant of course
you can also play stadia games with any
supported game controller or with a
mouse and keyboard the only other thing
you need is a screen to play on want to
play on the HD TV in your living room
just plug in a chromecast ultra if you'd
rather play on your laptop desktop or
tablet open a Chrome browser window our
vision is for stadia to run on any
screen that runs Chrome or you can use
the stadia app on your pixel three will
be expanding to more screens down the
line to including more smartphones when
you're ready to play the stadia
controller connects directly to your
game running in the Google Data Center
that direct connection is key to
providing the highest possible
performance and the best streaming
experience we have so many more details
on the stadia controller which you can
find at Stadio calm we're also a tweet
away at Google stadia to answer all your
questions we're very excited to
introduce you to a number of new titles
coming to stadia at launch
let's take a look I'm a wolf raised to
be the Alpha trying to follow
alas the Beast can't be tame that easily
this wild territory is the perfect in
for my kind a free world where I can
roam explore with no man but I came here
on the hunt
hidden among sheep focused on their
superficial dreams moving up the food
chain step by step before I dominate
them all one target always clearly in my
sights to secure the future with
technology others developed but were too
fearful to before but to think law I
took this island and by tooth and claw I
will rule it
the wolf knows when a predator nears can
a ghost take on the lone wolf
maybe track analyzing stalky patiently
tirelessly but there is no place for the
weak and the wounded here
we are wolf
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so Tom Clancy's the division to happen
seven months after a deadly pandemic
that started in New York spread not only
across the nation but also across the
world and knew as an agent that the
strategic homeland division has been
called to Washington DC to help take the
city back and save the country so one of
the major challenges is to take an RPG
and to create a fast-paced action-packed
shooting game we learn a lot from the
first game and we improved on that and
what we have today I think is the best
cover based shooter RPG out there one of
the real benefits of choosing Washington
DC for the second game is that we have
all of these amazing iconic buildings
the White House the Capitol we have the
Air and Space Museum we have the Lincoln
Memorial and of course there's even a
control point at the base of the
Washington Monument Stadium means that
you can play your game anywhere the
collaboration with Google has been
really awesome because they're very open
a very open company at least with us as
partners we know games and they know
infrastructure so together we can bring
a powerful visually appealing experience
to all stadia users together we can make
the best of it
the exciting part about partnering with
Google is that they really have the
bandwidth in just a physical
infrastructure to pull something like
this off
bringing the division to to stadia has
been a learning experience an immensely
thrilling journey so I'm really looking
forward to seeing what we can do in the
future
that's a look at just some of the
amazing titles were bringing to you at
launch and now here to tell you about
stay Diaz pricing and availability is my
friend and colleague John we're
launching stadia with a diverse mix of
games from lots of genres and
world-class game publishers there's
truly something for everyone with stadia
you can put your money toward the things
that really matter the latest greatest
game experiences that you can play
anywhere to unlock these experiences
we're offering a premium subscription
for our stadia players introducing
stadia Pro it delivers the best of
stadia for just $9.99 per month stadia
Pro gives you regular content that we
add to your library for being a stadia
Pro member and our highest streaming
quality 4k HD are 60 frames per second
with 5.1 surround sound and we're going
a step further to celebrate players who
want to be the first playing on Stadium
we know there's a passionate world of
players out there who want bigger better
more accessible gaming experiences after
announcing stadia we've heard from so
many gamers who share our excitement for
those fans we've created a custom
limited edition set of exclusive
features in content we call it the
stadia founders Edition and you can
pre-order it starting today the founders
edition includes everything you need to
get started with stadia and you'll have
the first access to stadia when it
launches later this year we want to make
sure your games look great on the
biggest screen in your home so the
founders edition comes with a chromecast
Ultra for streaming it up to 4k HDR
at 60 frames per second directly to your
TV you'll also receive a limited edition
night blue stadia controller as well as
three months of stadium pro and we know
gaming is more fun with a friend
the founders Edition comes with a three
month buddy pass so you can gift stadia
Pro access to a friend or family member
you can also pick up an additional
stadia controller for $69 it comes in
clearly white just black and wasabi
and here's the best part about the
founders edition you'll be among the
first players to secure your exclusive
stadia name so you'll get the stadia
name you want and the bragging rights
that go along with it so you're getting
a chromecast ultra the limited edition
night blue stadia controller three
months of stadia Pro for you and a
friend and you'll be among the first
players to select a stadia name it's all
in the stadia founders Edition and it's
coming to these 14 countries and we're
working hard to expand stadia to
additional countries in 2020 and beyond
we do have one more surprise gamers who
buy the stadia founders Edition will get
the complete destiny to experience as
part of stadia Pro let's take a look
Destin's about being a super powerful
hero set loose in a really beautiful
world the first time I fired my super I
was like screaming now I've been playing
games for 30 years I've never
experienced that destiny is about
playing with your friends my best
moments are with other players the first
time I beat both of class I know who was
there with me and that just makes it
fuel so much more rich bungees always
been at the forefront of exploring new
ways to bring our games to our players
we are now our own publisher did you
know this
and with stadia you get to be the tip of
the spear with something that's new our
push now is to remove all the barriers
that we have to playing destiny whenever
wherever with whomever you want you were
allowing players to have access to all
of it all of our planets all the
cooperative strikes all of our
competitive modes gambit raids it's all
there for players to jump in we can have
fun with shadow key
next chapter in the destiny story it's a
pre haunting tale there are these
nightmares that are walking the moon and
you'll have to find a way to conquer
these nightmares and face your fears we
have a lot to do with this material
we're not done yet
we now are in control of our own destiny
behind us we have an incredible
community and with stadia I think we're
gonna open up an entirely new
opportunity for players to come in and
play with their friends from around the
world
always brings us back to the past
can you feel them I can still hear their
voices
they're endless torment reshapes are
nightmares now stock the surface
walking shadows seeking vengeance our
old fears may rise again
and in the dark below
something wicked
has awakened
[Music]
we must bring an end to this suffering
one way
another
a big thank you to our friends at Bungie
for partnering with us to bring the full
destiny to experience two stadia the
base game all previous add-ons the
newest expansion and the annual pass
they're all included in your stadia Pro
subscription and as an added bonus
you'll be able to transfer your destiny
Guardian to stadium from any other
platforms to recap the stadia founders
Edition comes with limited edition night
glue controller chromecast ultra three
months of stadia pro the full destiny to
experience first dibs on your stadia
name and a buddy pass to give stadia Pro
to a friend for three months good luck
deciding who you're gonna give it to
when you add everything up that's almost
three hundred dollars of value and
you'll get it all in the founders
Edition for just $129 which you can
pre-order now we're excited to offer the
founders Edition to gamers around the
world but it's only available for a
limited time in limited quantities so
don't wait too long to pre-order if you
don't want the founders addition or
stadia Pro you can still buy and play
stadia games without a subscription
simply buy the games you want when you
want them we call the stadia base and
any games you purchase they're yours to
play whenever you want so whether you're
ready to go all-in with the founders
Edition bundle or if you prefer stadia
base you have options all right let's
bring Phil back for a few final details
and surprises thanks for tuning in to
this first look at some of our most
exciting launch titles pricing details
and how to access stadia right at launch
you can get more details and info at
Stadio comm slash FAQ or you can find it
in the description here or tweet us at
Google stadia we'll have much more to
come soon including additional
announcements from some of the world's
best game publishers thanks for watching
I can't wait for you to experience
stadia for yourself and with that we're
excited to show you one last collection
of games listen up already
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]